sur la façon de contrer l'épidémie
alexandra aurions côte généticienne nous
a rejoint alexandre à orio co2 merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors les tours de vis sanitaires se
multiplient dans le monde mais aussi en
france c'est ce qu'il était temps est ce
qu'on en fait on est ce qu'on en fait
trop est ce que ce sont des mesures
disproportionnées selon vous votre sujet
elle montre que déjà la france est un
bien grand mot puisque il ya une
diversité des territoires qui fait qu
effectivement pas typiquement la
guadeloupe est confronté à une réalité
autre que celle que nous vivons en
métropole et ce qui est intéressant
c'est quand même c'est de se dire que on
est arrivé à un stade où on a ou c'est
l'heure des bilans alors à part en
guadeloupe où ça visiblement ça commence
on est quand même à l'heure des bilans
c'est à dire que on est à la fin de
l'épidémie qu'on a vu qu'on n'a pas eu
d'excès de mentalité en europe entre les
0 et 65 ans qu'on a eus qu'on n'a pas eu
d'excès de mortalité les héros à 110 ans
dans plein pays comme l'autriche
l'allemagne danemark et la norvège
enfin mais pourquoi c'est pourquoi ça ne
pourrait pas repartir finalement
pourquoi vous nous butons enfin
d'épidémie ça pourrait pas repartir
selon vous alors ça repart ça ne tarde
pas c'est à dire qu'en fait on est là
effectivement on a un retour qu'on nous
qu'on est tout le temps en train nous
agiter un spectre de d'un fantôme
alors qu'est ce qui logiquement risque
de repartir comme chaque année à cette
saison enfin un peu plus tardivement
dans la saison c'est la grippe est ce
que vous parlez beaucoup de la grippe
alors que on sait maintenant que
finalement en termes de létalité on
arrive à des pourcentages qui sont très
proches de celui de la grippe
c'est là où il ya envoyé tout son espace
de de disproportion que je vois entre
l'état des choses l'état des chiffres
l'état du danger sanitaire comme vous
dites et et puis ce que nous vivons ce
que ce qu'on nous fait vivre notamment
par le port du masque dans un bon nombre
de jeux justement ce port du masque est
ce que vous le préconisez vous pour ceux
qui savent l'utiliser c'est bien cela
parce que c'est vrai parfois on porte
nomma au visage alors c'est quoi un
usage intelligent du masque finalement
j'ai envie de vous poser la question
c'est que finalement puisque je viens de
vous dire que on va en arriver à un
niveau de 2 connaissance du coc vide qui
fait qu'on n'attende et habité qui
équivalent à celui de la grippe est ce
que quand il va ya pourquoi est-ce que
vous mettiez pas des masques l'hiver
dernier quand il y avait la grippe
effectivement il ya eu cette épidémie de
kobe vous nous parler de la grippe de ce
fameux vaccin est ce que ça veut dire
alors qu'il faut qu'on se fasse vacciner
je parle pas du bâtiment là je vous
parle simplement de 2,2 fait que chaque
année il ya une épidémie de grippe que
cette année à en 2019 2020
on a eu plutôt moins de grip que
d'habitude on n'explique pas très bien
mais que dans les faits on a
chaque hiver un épisode grippal
est-ce qu'il faut se faire vacciner
comme le nombre des autorités
est ce que vous êtes pour une
vaccination massive contre la grippe
saisonnière celle qu'on connaît pour
finalement davantage identifier les les
malades ducobu 19 déjà vous me demandiez
sur le masque donc je vous ai répondu
par une question à laquelle vous n'avez
pas vraiment répondu vous m'avez répondu
en me posant une autre question sur le
vaccin
marino intéresse personne c'est vous
l'experte
oui mais mais l'expert que je suis peux
vous dire qu'il n'y a aucune indication
il n'y a jamais eu de démonstrations
scientifiques qui montrent un intérêt de
porter un masque par des personnes
saines pour aucune pathologie dans aucun
système
donc ça c'est la réalité c'est-à-dire
n'y a pas d'études scientifiques les
seules études scientifiques qu'on a eue
sur le masque c'était des études qui
montrait qu'il fallait pas porter un
titre d'un masque en tissu dans un cadre
hospitalier
et ça ça a été montré dans différents
pays dans la même étude
au risque de contracter une infection de
type grippal
pourquoi parce que en fait le tissu on
provoque un espoir à permet de faire une
petit écran qui coussinets ou vous
risquez de vous re est infecté deux
autos quand contaminés donc ça c'est
quand même une chose qui est connu et
d'ailleurs que l' oms décrit
parfaitement dans ces indications et
dans ses conseils à porter le masque ce
qu'il fait qu'il nous ne préconise pas
le masque dans par le grand public dans
des lieux aéré pour conclure en quelques
secondes vous insisté aussi sur la bonne
hygiène de vie pourquoi c'est
indispensable en ce moment c'est
indispensable en ce moment parce qu'en
fait la saison nous permet de finalement
faire un espèce de petit accumulation
notre stop de vitamine d qui est
fondamental pour dans notre réaction
face à des infections respiratoires
voilà donc ça c'est ça c'est encore une
fois c'est un communiqué de presse qu'on
a eue alors sur le co vide en
particulier par l'académie de médecine
une très tôt rendant dans la crise qu
vide et c'est une certitude donc 7 juin
de vie luis et puis si moment où on peut
faire du sport sans sens en difficulté
parce qu'il fait encore très beau l'avez
remarqué
donc c'est le moment où on peut remettre
notre système d' attaque pour des mômes
des périodes un peu plus froide et où
plus de virus circule et notamment celui
de la grippe
et puis et puis celui du peu vide qui va
forcément continuer à circuler
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est ce
qu'il faut continuer à distinguer la
grippe due qu'aux villes où est-ce qu on
peut désormais traiter l'entité grippale
qu'ovide grippe ce qui me semblerait
plus judicieux compte tenu de ce qu'on
connaît encore une fois de la létalité
du coc vide donc ça c'est un aspect
après sur l'aspect vaccin intérêt ou non
en quelques mots pour conclure une
nouvelle fois fait peu de temps alors
vacciner je vois que toutes les
indications sont au vert en disant
foncez vous vacciner braves gens contre
la grippe
cette année c'est un point que j'ai
appelé à discuter il ya déjà quelques
mois
pourquoi parce que la solitude dont je
dispose est une étude où ils ont pris
trois mille personnes sont vaccinées
contre la grippe 3000 personnes qu'ils
n'ont pas vacciner contre la grippe
et dans le lot de ceux qui étaient
vaccinés ils ont pu constater une
augmentation des infections
respiratoires d'une façon générale et
notamment des infections respiratoires
dues aux kora n'est pas un coronavirus
alors c'était pas le cofidis bien que
8,19 meyssan et
donc j'aime seulement un point très
important à poser avant de dire de se
ruer sur le vaccin de la grippe stadia
cas si vous me demandez aujourd'hui ce
qu'elle est ma position je n'en ai pas
je veux qu on confronte les spécialistes
et s'est contenté afrique notamment
merci merci beaucoup alexandra henrion
côte d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes généticienne